what i like about your book is you admit
to being a shitty actress when you start
people don't talk about that acting like
anything else you have to work hard at
it yeah you know you were kind of a
delightful kid and everything but at the
same point when you get on these tv
shows and you get bit parts yeah you
said you were kind of shitty i still
might be you over you think you're still
a shitty actress probably yeah why are
you not great king of queens i mean that
puts you on the map everybody you know
certain shows can't go like oh my god
lee is still mugging like i'm like my
accent got thicker i was like nothing
i like that you auditioned for friends
for example yeah i think that's great i
mean imagine if you'd gotten that part
whatever you you're watching
you auditioned for the uh courtney uh
cox role right yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's hard right i mean you walk into a
room and you got to win a crowd you see
the success you know
what i'm like sitting there looking for
you know taco bell money into my purse
when you would watch friends and it was
a huge success yeah you say [ __ ] if i
had just gotten that role right damn it
my life could have been good right now
yes of course right but then you know
when you get your show which is what
king of queens was for me that was my
part that was my show i was meant to
have that part you know then you then
you can look back and go that wasn't
meant to be but the moment you can't pay
your rent and your car is getting
repossessed you're not happy about it
when you first audition for king of
queens with uh kevin james
kevin have the final say on that because
wasn't he the creator of the show kevin
was the one of the creators of the show
do you have any idea how many people
they auditioned for your role
uh i don't know but kevin when i met
kevin it was like instant it was instant
chemist some people you meet
in this business that you have instant
chemistry with did you think that the
show was going to be as big as it was
again i was like i'm probably this is
going to get count because it's too
normal for people because you had been
through this before you had gotten
sitcoms your own sitcom right and you
thought oh this is it i'm going to be
rich i'm going to be famous i'm going to
be the big biggest actress in the world
and then they don't work cancelled most
sitcoms original shows do not work
they're horror scenes right so when
after doing all kinds of bit parts on
all these shows and working uh hard at
your craft then you get king of queens
and by then you're smart enough to know
this probably won't go i'd probably i
wouldn't even put like a usually i
decorate everybody's room like the first
day you know and i was like i'm not even
putting a candle here right you know so
uh yes
not because i didn't think it was good i
thought it was great i was like it's so
good it probably won't make it
because shows are looking to do
different things and this is a show
about a family right and so when kevin
james you but you do say in your book
there were a lot of arguments on set
right you and kevin you and kevin did
have beef once in a while no we we we
had a normal relationship and the only
reason i point that out howard is
because i'm so tired like i i hate when
people go we're like family we'll just
get along a lot of [ __ ] yeah your
family gets along you ever fight yeah if
you didn't fight you're not like a
family right yeah what would be the
fights because you'd say hey my
character doesn't feel authentic or i
wouldn't say that kind of thing what
would the fight be would be just
something somebody said i wanted greek
food right oh that's what it would
in other words they didn't treat you
properly on the side no that wasn't it i
mean me and kevin isn't it like i said
what are we getting for lunch we decided
it was greek and then he got italian
sometimes don't you look back on that
and think how ridiculous that we would
fight about this we didn't really fight
i mean i'm being funny that we were
fighting but i just i'm only saying that
because we actually just really had a
real relationship